Alright. So having gone through that exercise, Michael, I think it's,
it's worthwhile to step back a little bit and think about
the assumptions that we've been making that have been mostly unspoken.
And I'm going to say that the main assumption that we've been
making in some sense boils down to a single word. And
that word is stationary. So let me tell you what I
mean by that and why by kind of illustrating what it
is we've been sort of doing for a little while. Okay?
>> Sure.
>> Okay. So the first thing I'm going to say is that we've actually been.
Kind of assuming infinite horizons. So what do I
mean by that. When, when we think about the last
grid world that we were playing with, we basically said
well, you know, I want to avoid going to the
end as quickly as possible if I have rewards of
a certain value or whatever. Because, you know, the game
doesn't end until I get to an absorbing state. Well,
that sort of implies. That you basically can live forever.
That you have an infinite time horizon to work
with. Now can you, can you imagine why if
you didn't have an infinite time horizon to work
with you might end up doing something very different?
>> Different then what, what we're doing in the grid world?
>> Right, so here let me let me show you the
game that we were, the grid world that we were doing before.
Might help you think about it. So here's the grid world
we had before. And as you recall. We had a particular policy
that sort of made sense. Here, I'll, I'll
write it out for you again. And this was
with a case where we had a reward
of minus 0.04. Remember? We just did this. Remember?
>> Yep.
>> Okay, and this was the policy that turned out to be
optimal, and in the future I want you to pay attention to
here is that when you're over right here near possible end state,
rather than going up, it made sense to take the long way around.
Because you're going to get some negative
reward but it's a small enough negative
reward compared to where you might end up. Okay with a positive one.
>> Yeah, I see.
>> And that makes some sense. Well, that only makes sense if you're
going to be living long enough that you can take the long route around.
What if I told you you only had say three times steps left,
and then the game is going to end no matter where you end up?
>> Well, it might be,
it might make more sense to take some risk than just try
to take the short way because there's really no chance you're going to
get to the plus1. I'm entirely convinced of that though because there's
still a chance you'll fall into the minus 1 along the way.
>> Right, so the exact val, whether it makes sense to take the risk
or not is going to depend upon two things, we've already talked about one of
them which is the actual word that you get. If this reward were, you
know, negative enough, then clearly it makes sense to just try to end things
quickly, right? We just showed that in the last quiz. But
another thing that it's going to depend upon is how much time you
have in order to get to where you're going. If you've
only got one or two time steps before everything's going to end. You
can imagine that there are cases where, without changing the reward
too much it makes a lot of sense to try to go
ahead and quickly get to this plus 1, even though you
have some chance of falling into the minus 1. As opposed to,
trying to move away, where you're then kind of, all but guaranteed that
you're never going to reach the plus 1. So. Whether it makes sense to
take the risk or not will depend upon the reward but it's also
going to depend upon whether you have an infinite amount of time to get
to where you want to get to or whether you have a finite
amount of time. And the real major thing I want you to get
out of that is that if you don't have an infinite horizon but
you have a finite horizon then two things happen. One is the policy might
change because things might end. But secondly, and more
importantly, the policy can change, or will changee., even
though you're in the same state. So, if I
told you, if you're in this state right here, and
I told you you didn't have an infinite amount
of time, but you still had 100 million time steps
then, it, I think it's clear that it still
makes sense to go the long way around, right? Yeah,
I mean the, the probability that this policy is going to
last for a million timesteps has got to be tiny.
>> Right. So, I might as well. It's 100
million timesteps might as well be infinity. But if
I make that number not 100 million but I make it 2, or 3, or 4. Then suddenly
your calculus might change. In particular, your caluculus will
change even though I'm in the same state. Right?
So maybe this state right here, if I've got
a million, 100 million timesteps I still want got
to go the long way around, but if I've only got a few time steps, the only
way I'm ever going to get a positive reward
is to go this way. Does that make sense?
>> I guess so. So, you're saying, for
example, even within the single run, it could be
that I'm in a state and I try an action and maybe it doesn't work and I
stay where I am. And I try it again, and maybe it doesn't work and I stay
where I am. It might then switch to a
different action, not because the other one wasn't working,
but because now it's running out of time. Right, exactly. So
we talked about this notion of a policy which maps states to
actions, we talked about this notion about stationarity. So you believe
that this sort of Markovian thing said, it doesn't matter where I've
been it only matters where I am. And so if i'm
in this state, since it only matters where I am, I'm always
going to want to take the same action. Well that's only true in this
kind of infinite horizon case. If you're in a finite horizon case.
And that finite horizon, of course, is going
to keep counting down, every time you take a
step. Well then suddenly, depending upon the time
step that's left, you might take a different action.
So we could write that I think, just for the sake of kind of seeing it as
some thing like, your policy is a function both
the stature and, and the time step you're in.
>> Hm. And that might lead you to a different set of
actions. So this is important, this is important, I mean were not,
we are not, for, for this course going to talk about this
case at all, where you're in a finite horizon, but I think
it's important for you to understand that the, without this infinite horizon
assumption here. You loose this function of stationarity in your policies. Okay?
>> Yeah. Interesting.
>> Okay. So, that all, I think is, you
know, making our something that's obvious, but becomes obvious
after someone points it out to you. So, the
second thing that I want to talk about, I think,
is a little bit more subtle. And, and this notion
of utility of sequences. So, as we've been talking, Michael, we
have been sort of. Implicitly discussing not just the rewards we
get in a single state, but the rewards that we get
through a sequences of states that we take. And so
I just want to point out a little fact that that comes
from that, and where that ends up leading us. And then
we'll get to some nice little cute series of math. So.
Here's what I want to point what utilities, what we mean by
utilities sequences. It means we have some function I'm going to call
U for utility over the state, the sequence, sorry. Of states
that we're going to see let's call them, S0, S1, S2 and
so on and so forth. Well, I think an assumption that
we've been making even if we haven't been very explicit about
it is that if we had two sequences of states. S0,
S1, S2, dot dot dot. And a different sequence S0, then S1
prime and S2 prime, that is two sequences that
might differ from S1 on, but all start in
the same start state. Okay? If we have a
utility for the first, and that utility happens to be
greater than the utility for the second, then it
also turns out that we believe. That the utility
for S1, S2, dot dot dot, is greater than
the utility for S1 prime, S2 prime dot dot dot.
>> Alright
so these are two different sequences, S one, the
S's and the S prime's are two different sequences.
>> Yes.
>> And in the beginning we're comparing them with S0 stuck in
front of both of them. And we're saying if I prefer the
S0 followed by all the S's, to S0 followed by the S
primes, then I have that same preference even with those S0s missing.
>> Right, and so this is called stationarity of preferences.
And, another way of saying it is. That
if I prefer one sequence of states today over
another sequence of states, then I prefer that sequence
of states over the same sequence of states tomorrow.
>> So isn't, isn't this just obvious?
Because the whatever the rewards for those two
cases, we're just adding the reward we get
for S0. So. It's going to be the same.
>> But listen to what
you just said. You just said, well, it'll be the same, because all we're doing
is adding the reward for S0. But what did we ever say about adding up rewards?
>> I thought, I thought that's what we were doing.
>> That's right, that is what we were doing. But we
never actually sat down and wrote that down and said, this is
what it means. To talk about the utility of a sequence of
states as opposed to the reward that you get in one state.
>> Okay, so you're saying that if
we, if we are adding rewards, then this follows.
>> Right.
>> Okay.
>> And then I've actually been saying something even stronger,
which is, I will show you on the next slide,
which is if you believe that this is true, that
the utility of one sequence of states is greater than the
utility of another sequence of states. Both today and tomorrow.
Then it actually forces you to do some variation of what
you said which is just adding sequences of states. Or
adding the rewards of the sequence of states that we see.
>> That's really interesting. So then, so the adding isn't
really an arbitrary thing it follows from this, this deeper assumption.
>> Right, and the reason I bring this up is
because. It would make sense if you were to just to
grab someone off the street and start talking about Marco Decision
Processes. One of two things will happened. Either they'd run screaming
from you like you're a crazy person or they would
sit and they would listen and if they listen they would
just completely buy into the idea that you just add up
sequences of rewards. You know, sequences of rewards that you see
as a way of talking about how good the states are because
that's a very natural thing to do. But it turns out that mathematicall
if you have this notion. A sort of stationary of preferences and this
sort of infinite arise in world. You really are in a case where
this has to be true. And it has to be the case
if you have to do some form of addition. Because nothing else sort
of can be guaranteed to maintain
this property over stationary preferences. I mean,
as you said, if I got one sequences of states and another sequnce
of states and by just prepending or appending another
set of states to it, I'm still going to always
guarantee that one's greater than the other. You kind
of have to do some form of adding the reward
that you see in the states in both cases.
because if you don't do that, then eventually this inequality
will not hold. So, let me write that down
in math terms. And see where that gets us, okay?
>> Cool.